mais d'abord les étudiants face à la
montée de la pauvreté ils ont été parmi
les premiers à perdre leur job pendant
cette crise sanitaire
alors pour les aider les associations
tourangelle multiplient les actions
parmi les plus anciennes les halles de
rabelais sur le campus grand nom de
distribution alimentaire mensuelle dont
une hier soir elle a attiré vous allez
le voir plusieurs centaines d'étudiants
samuel colin le mardi de 18 à 20 heures
distribution de colis alimentaires à la
maison des étudiants nationaux ou
internationaux
depuis la rentrée de septembre ils sont
30% de plus à venir ici une fois tous
les quinze jours
sans cette aide ça aurait été quand même
assez difficile on va dire d'avoir des
semaines on peut se nourrir deux fois
par jour tranquillement
des numéros et un passage par ordre
d'arrivée pour les deux premières venues
la carte d'étudiant suffit moi
personnellement c'est ma première fois
et bon j'avoue clé ça m'aide pour
limiter les abus il faut ensuite
justifié ses ressources et cotiser pour
10 euros annuels l'association étudiants
clé al de rabelais existe depuis 2009 la
plupart des bénévoles sont d'ailleurs
d'anciens bénéficiaires
mais ce second confinement aggrave
encore davantage une précarité déjà
existantes
ça a été impactée par le cos vides il y
en a des étudiants qui ont peu de
ressources ou prix ont perdu leur camp
perdu leur travail de la clé n'ont pas
de bourse
et puis on n'a que les arrivent de
l'étranger et ils ont pas
ils ont pas en fait beaucoup de social
la solidarité se fait aussi entre
associations ce soir les fruits et
légumes viennent d'une autre structure
les jardins de yolande et le secours
populaire ouvre une permanence à
l'université objectif faire connaître
ses actions et ses autres antennes on
les orientera et puis on peut on va
essayer on va tenter de leur proposer
une aide pour limiter la fracture
numérique
en tout 400 bénéficiaires repartent avec
des colis dont la moitié viennent pour
la première fois